[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because appearing on the show for the
third time she is in the hat-trick club
it's amazing it's Olivia Scott Welch who
is now Julie and lucky Hank which is on
AMC and AMC plus how you doing today
Olivia I'm doing so good how are you I'm
doing great I'm so excited to talk to
you again I know I'm outside at my third
time this is so exciting yeah I feel
like we've I've like somehow been on
this journey with you together from
Panic to fear I know that is what it
feels like that is I would it would be
such a shame if it ever the pattern ever
broke I know please just don't forget
about me Olivia
here's the thing so first off I love the
show I'm excited it's finally out
um so I know a lot of people ask this
question but I am curious in this
specific case because we've seen your
career going up and up how did you get
this part was it through some previous
work was it through auditions you have
to do kind of the same usual process
yeah it was literally just uh a self
tape I got over the summer
um and it was like a thing where I got
the self tape and then I
um like was like okay I have to do this
self tape and then I went over to like
one of my best friends Robbie's house
and I was gonna help him with the self
tape and I was like can you go ahead and
help me with this self tape and then um
we ended up just like having a lot of
fun doing it and it was something where
I was like oh I feel very like I did a
good job
everyone's in a blue moon you do an
audition where you're like I actually
felt like I did a good job actually and
this was one of those and then um I sent
it off and then uh
like was went and visited my parents and
found out I was going to meet with Paul
lieberstein and Peter Fairley and then I
did my second meeting with them from
like the kitchen of my childhood home
so that was really fun okay so that's
really cool and you you mentioned Paulie
Racine Peter Farrelly directing the
first two episodes and then you're
working side by side with Bob Odenkirk
so these are some Heavy Hitters you're
saying here sorry are you yeah is there
an intimidation factor for this for you
was it a little scary at first
it really okay weirdly like with Bob and
I keep saying this and then every time I
feel worse and worse I never watched
Breaking Bad or Better Call Saul
so I know and I have to do it now
especially because I he's like my dad
now and I have to support
um but I but I I knew him a lot from
Comedy because my dad is like a huge SNL
fan and him and my dad are around the
same age so it was like
Bob was one of the comedians that my dad
like showed me as a kid and then would
show me like his episodes of SNL and
stuff so that was like more exciting and
then that's kind of something that we
like how we kind of got to know each
other was talking about like comedy and
then like comedy from the 70s and like
British comedy from the 90s and like all
these random bits of the comedy world
and then yeah like Paul
it was kind of CR I was like this is so
crazy and then but he's so sweet and
like him and I became um he's such a
lovely person I feel like we became
really good buddies so fast that I would
forget very quickly that he's like on
one of the most famous TV shows of all
time
yeah yeah 100 and it's so excited to see
you here you deserve it and I think it's
interesting too but you mentioned the
comedy and the SNL with Bob Odenkirk so
I was going to ask you about that with
the comedy part of it was it exciting to
be working in that comedy realm and you
have really good comedic timing and
chops here so thank you was there also
like room to improvise as well how is
that whole feel of it oh yeah oh these
are great questions
um yeah doing comedy was so exciting
because I had always
wanted to do it and when I started
acting it was like what I where my like
my strengths lied and um and then like
when I moved to LA I like went through
all of the Upright Citizens Brigade
program which is like Amy Poehler and
Matt Walsh's like improv School
um so I always kind of thought that
that's like where I would end up but
then like the the universe was like no
we want to see you covered in Wood you
stab and be stabbed and I was like oh
okay interesting
um so it's cool to like kind of
like complete that Circle I guess and be
on something that's so fun and funny and
then
yeah there was like the scripts were so
good so good immediately but also Aaron
Zellman and Paul lieberstein who was
there wrote it together and were our
share writers they were like so genius
in their writing and then would also be
like very
um open to people improving and stuff so
that was really cool because they really
let everybody like if you had an idea
you could pitch it and um if you were
like I have an idea like an ALT for this
line that's a joke like I've also come
up with a separate joke and they'd be
like okay we'll say it and so uh they
were very encouraging of like everybody
using all their comedic skills as much
as they could which was cool yeah I I
love that and I love seeing everyone
work together too and yeah what I really
like is that when I was watching the
show I felt like the family feels like a
very real family you're in oh good it's
almost scary so and it's also scary
there's a scary there's you know related
it all works it's casting really well so
with your on-screen parents how did you
get I was like find that together like
how do you work through that with just
like scene partners
oh man well they're both like
two of the most talented people I will
ever meet in my entire life like I was
telling me Ray the other day I was like
I don't know what it is about you but I
went a lot and shouted all of our
directors and our showrunner and I just
and our actors like I just went every
day that I wasn't filming myself and me
Ray was someone that she would be doing
a scene and I would be like wow and I
would like start crying and I am like
not a crier I very rarely cry in real
life but she's so good at acting that it
like made me emotional because I was
like I've never encountered a woman
that's so down did
um in my life and the same with Bob and
like yeah so I before like we started
filming like the three of us would hang
out when I booked the role the next day
Bob called me and I missed it because it
was an unknown number I was like
whatever and then I got a voicemail that
was like hi Olivia this is Bob Odenkirk
and I was like oh oh no but it was like
the nicest voicemail I've ever received
in my life and I'm happy that I have it
now but um the three of it he like
invited me over to lunch and like him
and me Ray had been hanging out like
once a week and and he was like you
should come to our hangout and then uh
we just like hung out at his house for
like a while and just kind of got to
know each other and then like read some
of our scenes from the pilot and then
kind of kept doing that throughout
filming but
the cast just got really close like
everybody was together all the time and
so it made it because also the whole
like with the Ensemble of the
the teachers
why am I blanking on this no you got it
the department the department oh yeah
the department they were all like part
of the comedy of them comes from the
fact that they've all known each other
like way too well for like 15 years so
they everybody just wanted to make sure
that we were all like close and then it
just became where everybody really loved
spending time with each other so we
spent a lot of time together but then
Bob and miray are just like incredible
and I feel like it was such a gift to
play
a like a daughter on a show that's like
a character in full but they also have
like two parents that are full
characters
yes it was like they would do stuff and
I'd be like oh if if these were actually
my parents like what would I have picked
up subconsciously and what would I have
like rejected and um what would I do and
think that it's different from them but
also it's basically just the same thing
so it was like a really fun new
um thing to do as an actor because I've
never had that full of a family Dynamic
on a in a project before yeah really fun
yeah sure and I like you mentioned too
that's not just like a typical daughter
character that there's depths to the
character yeah I also like that there's
a mysterious thing I've taken from
seeing a couple of the First episodes of
Julie that I like that this show is like
slowly rolling out more information
about her as we go on yeah
for you did you have like a giant you
know Julie Bible like do you go to
extremes to know your character inside
and out or do you not go that intense
with it oh this is a good question too
um I feel like
I feel
um from an acting teacher like a class I
did like when I was really young this
like
questionnaire about characters and I
think it was maybe initially for writers
but I use it like when I'm acting and
have always and then also like when I've
been writing things but it's like from
like
what's a childhood memory of theirs that
they didn't seem like a big deal at the
time and now haunts them every day you
know and then but it'd also be like do
they have a favorite song
and so it's like really runs the gamut
of like human
thought so I use that every time and
then I'll do like just some like light
journaling and stuff but also
um the book that this is based on is
like incredible it's so good and so that
was really cool to got like I got to
read that before we started filming and
then
um Aaron and Paul had a we had like a
sit down with them and um Mark Johnson
who was like our big executive producer
and then Bob and Ray Ray and me when we
read some scenes and we kind of just
talked about like the things that they
wanted to be different from the book for
each of the characters and like what
they wanted to change and like if the
storyline would stay the same and so I
kind of just used all of that and then
truly watching Bob and Mirai I was like
this is such an education because you
can prep all day by yourself but then
the minute you get on set like it's
truly a wild card as to what other
people will do
and I was like they're
um amazing that's really incredible so I
was like I'm gonna kind of take their
lead and like see what they're doing and
adapt from there and that was really fun
that's that's really cool and I like
you're going into the craft there but I
also wonder because you've had a couple
of big projects under your belt now is
there anything that maybe when you
started out you did that you don't like
to do anymore it's something you've
learned or changed in your process as an
actress so you're just like you know
what I'm done with that that's good
that's good I feel like
um
oh this is such a good question I feel
like it does kind of change a little
every time I've weirdly like gotten I
used to write a ton like a ton on my
sides for that day and like a ton behind
that like I used to just write and write
and write and then like
I've kind of like gotten half and half
now to where I try to really find it
like in my body
like get it on its feet and
um that has been something that I've
like done and so now like sometimes I'll
like do scenes and like walk around my
house or like go on a walk and then like
do them I feel like like movement has
become a lot more um precious to me also
because I'm very
awkward in real life and I'm sure and
this is not even getting down on myself
I wish you could see my full body as to
how I'm sitting right now I'm really
expecting this
um that I
in characters I'm like not everybody can
be like like this person they have to
all be different so I think I think that
that's been a cool thing that I'm trying
to work on now
and it's made me want to do like a play
or something like I'm like I want to do
something where you can just rehearse
for forever before you do it for real
yeah I like that you're bringing that
physicality to it and feeling to it
that's really good advice in general
um do you yourself as a viewer enjoy
this week to week format with the show
like this yeah I do it was it was
exciting because it was um I also get
like burned out on things very quickly I
feel like just because there's like such
a overexposure of
content out there but I and it's fun
like I watched this
um I watched I watched it on Sunday
night with like one of my best friends
who's McCabe from Fear Street oh hell
yeah because he's one of my best friends
um I watched it at his house with his
roommates and then like he's an actor
but then like the rest of them aren't
actors and and like Mark who's one of
their roommates he like is a music
supervisor but then like one of their
roommates Isaac is like in law so it was
fun to watch it with them
because they don't all do exactly the
same thing and I wanted to see like what
the group would think but they were all
saying they're like it's fun that we can
like get together and do something on
um a Sunday night and then like kind of
have that old school like tradition to
bring back
yeah I started watching Survivor okay
and I have a lot of Survivor since maybe
I was seven years old but they were like
we should watch Survivor every week and
I was like you know what anything to
feel like it's 1998 again yeah anyway
that shows addictive Survivor too man
that's that's great and that you're
right though it's like it's also like
great too that you get to savor it each
week and really discuss each episode
because I feel like with the binge model
yeah it appears through it you know
um yeah I just want to bring up two it
was awesome you posted Reddit corporate
photos for the uh show and I noticed in
them though that you have these smaller
tattoos on your wrists your arms oh yeah
been something though that's like do you
have to cover that with makeup or
clothes when you're doing a role or if
you notice that's kind of changing a lot
nowadays that is kind of changing it was
funny because I weirdly unlike most of
the things I've ever booked they just
throw me in a sweater which is such okay
all the time and that's how it was for
this like because it was so cold and
they very I'm so grateful to everybody
who decided that it could just be the
season that it was in real life on the
show
um because never that never happens and
you're just like uncomfortable one way
or the other uh but this it was like
they're like it's fall winter so it's
fall winter
um but yeah for this show they like
really didn't care and it was funny too
even like they were like oh yeah you can
have those out it's fine none of them
are like any copyright of any kind you
can't like show like
a Mickey Mouse tattoo if you have one
but
um yeah they have to like get that
cleared but all of mine are just like
with the weird little things that I've
drawn or my friends have drawn
so yeah and then um yeah like I also
like didn't
they didn't really do anything to my
hair and I really am not wearing very
much makeup in the show either which was
funny like they kind of were just like
we just want you to look as is oh they
just had me they were like we just like
we just like you and we're gonna put you
on screen love it I love it and it's
interesting too I I also wonder because
we've mentioned it a couple times with
Pierce Street but yeah with that an
enormous success of PS3 films and the
exposure it gave you yeah was it like
tough coming down from that high
afterwards meaning like did you have the
like leaving Disney World feeling like
that last day of vacation like is that
what that kind of felt like
it's so funny I was talking about this
the other day
it's like
I don't know there's like a weird thing
that compartmentalizes in my brain I
feel like because
I like you do it and it's so like work
heavy like even the press and stuff is
so work heavy and I also have very like
like not shy but uh
I'm not like out here being like who's
gonna recognize me today you know like
um so I feel like with fear it was
like but it's funny because people will
come up and be like I loved Fear Street
and I'm like oh my gosh yeah like the
thing that I did in my real life it was
on it was on TV you're trying like it's
funny that because you like live it and
you live it start to finish
and then uh
you like go and and that still hasn't
fully like clicked in my brain like I
was even on um the IMDb app yesterday my
favorite app of all time and there was
like an ad for
um lucky Hank
on the IMDb app and for a second like my
brain scrambled and was like is this a
screenshot from your phone
and then I was like oh no it's this is a
real ad like this isn't even for me this
is because it's on because this people
are gonna watch this TV show
so it's it's very like I just feel like
it's a weird thing where I don't think
about it often that it's like out there
yeah that's it makes total sense and
then I'll be like walking around and
someone's like I loved your movie and
I'm like oh
you're right I told
a movie I did not remember that I did
that you're totally totally right yeah
yeah and I feel like it hits that sweet
spot where like you get to still have a
life with it too which is great yeah and
I I have to bring up you mentioned IMDb
app because I'm obsessed with the IMDb
app um do you rate everything you watch
tell me right every episode of
everything oh my goodness I do rate on
IMDb I don't know
same
for I'm there for some reason I'm like
movies or movies yeah yeah everything is
beautiful if you made a movie then like
good for you yes I can like it but I can
also not like it and yeah you know put
it on IMDb I'm like 6.3 yeah like you're
like really brutal with it I'm the same
way I love that yeah you can like
contribute to the overall score
um yeah now speaking of just you had
mentioned earlier about like it's so
cool you're doing comedy now but you
know you're known also for the horror so
you got two hearts still on the way with
the blue rose and the Sacrifice game is
there anything you can tell us about
either
oh
um I got to do ADR for Sacrifice game
the other day anyway stunning like I
because you don't ever know like when
you're shooting something they're like
we're gonna set the shot up and we're
gonna put this lens on and we're gonna
color it this way and you're like that's
awesome that's great and then you can
kind of imagine it in your head but then
you see it and you're like oh this is
just not
I just would have never you know because
you're on the other side of it but then
Sacrifice game the other day I was like
Jen our director I was like this is
stunning oh that's exciting I got to see
like our opening titles and stuff and it
looks really good is uh ADR a weird
experience doing that like is it strange
it's strange but it literally is uh
I am addicted
like because it's like a game that you
play with yourself like it's like a game
where it's like like it's like you watch
it and then it's like they you watch it
with you talking and then I'll explain
it for everybody at home and then they
turn the sound off and you have to talk
in the exact same way that you did
before on screen and so sometimes I'm
like you know why this is off it's
because I took a breath right after that
word let me go again and I love it so
much
and it's because I've also done so much
of it now like with panic like I did
hours and hours of it
um wow
yeah because I was just on screen so
much and then like we were filming
outside so often that I 80 yard like so
much of that show and I also had to do
voiceovers and stuff
so I feel like now
I'm really I've I love it it's like
playing Tetris let me tell you you're
good you're good at it because I did not
notice it at all in panic so Props
you're an ADR are just oh thank you so
much thank you so much proud of yourself
um I have to ask the question everyone's
been like wanting me to ask you but
um you you have linked on your Spotify
bio I mean your Instagram bio Spotify
playlist that you've curated yeah do you
have a favorite one or you're most proud
of oh there's pool party there's
Botanical hitchhiker atmospheric River
Maybe
oh yeah these are pretty good some of
these I made in Vancouver because
someone said atmospheric River and
that's what it's called like I learned
this phrase in Vancouver but that's like
what the phrasing is for like when water
collects on the street and like rushes
down
that's an atmospheric River and so
that's like a rainy day playlist okay
the pool party one I think if it's what
it is it's like haunted house music is
it that's something that Chris Nelson
from Fear Street told me Chris Nelson
was our special effects guy and he is an
Oscar for Suicide Squad he's like he's
also the groom and Kill Bill wow I know
he's like prolific and every day I would
be like hey Chris how are you uh crazy
that you're here and I'm here as well
and I'm looking for literally like six
four in my life but he had this really
great playlist that he would play when
we were getting like Prosthetics on and
it was always like Monster Mash and like
the Monsters theme and stuff and I was
like this is great playlist and he
literally said to me it's my pool party
playlist oh that joke from him and that
I love it it's now yeah no it's cool so
you know the big Olivia Welch fans now
can have music curated by you it's
awesome so check that out in her bio on
Instagram
um
yeah
um and everyone watch Olivia kill it in
Lucky Hank on AMC and AMC plus there's a
new episode each week Olivia thank you
for joining me for a third time it means
so much it's so fun every time it is and
I hope one day there'll be a fourth I
really I think there will I agree I
agree soon soon soon
thanks Olivia all right bye